[Music]
we seek our logos every day whatever
sort of motor it is there's usually
something to tell us what it is some of
them are beautiful some of them are
clever but all have a story to tell
that's why today we're gonna tell you
about some of them be sure to stay tuned
to the end to find out how one of the
world's biggest car firms has stuck with
one thing on its logo for more than a
century if this is your first time
watching one of our videos then please
give us a big thumbs up and hit the
subscribe button here are the stories
behind the world's most famous car logos
mercedes-benz mercedes-benz has probably
got the longest history of any car
company in the world Karl Benz invented
the world's first combustion engine in
Germany in 1879 and developed the
world's first car the Benz patent
Motorwagen but it was in 1925 after the
Benz firm merged with Daimler that the
company's laurel wreath the ancient
Greek symbol of victory thought combined
with Daimler three-pointed star the star
has three points to symbolize where
Daimler's engines could go land water
and air as time went on the laurel
wreath was transformed into a plain
silver circle however the star remains
and helps make it one of the most iconic
logos in all of motoring also if you're
wondering where the Mercedes name comes
from Daimler's designer was an Austrian
called Emil Jelinek when he designed a
racing car in 1902 he named it after his
daughter Mercedes but it's not just
Mercedes jelinek who proved to be an
important woman in the history of the
company Karl Benz is wife Bertha was
perhaps the first woman driver to show
just how good her husband's early car
was she used to drive the couple's
teenage sons Eugen and Richard the 60
mile trip from Mannheim to forth time to
visit her mother this trip helped show
the public at large that the Benz car
was both reliable and safe Toyota
Toyotas logo is like those of many
Japanese firms interesting distinctive
and unusual but have you ever wondered
what the design actually means well it
was first introduced in 1989
fifty years after the company was first
founded the firm had been getting more
and more successful outside of Japan and
it was decided that it was time to come
up with something new before then the
company had just used its name in a
blocky red font the symbol that you see
has many different parts if you look
closely you'll see that there are three
ovals the ones which cross over each
other represent the heart of the
customer and the heart of the company
Toyota wanted something that showed the
driver trusted the firm and that the
firm trusted the driver in return it did
that by overlapping them they also form
something that kind of looks like a tee
for Toyota it also bears a resemblance
to a steering wheel bringing everything
back to the main point the car itself
the blank space behind the logo also has
a meaning it stands for the Toyota
concept of infinite values Cadillac if
there was one car that summed up the
American dream it was the Cadillac this
was a car that was attractive powerful
fun to drive distinctive and confident
just the very name can bring forward
thoughts of cruising down the freeway
with the top rolled down and listening
to classic 1950s rock and roll but the
origins of both the company's name and
its logo come a long way from the United
States of America and Towanda lamode
Cadillac was a minor member of the
French nobility who in 1701 founded a
fort in North America this fort was
named for Cronshaw trains to Detroit the
pole short train was for the French
minister the Colt DuPont rail train the
Detroit part of the name comes from the
Detroit River which it sat next to as
the years went on the fort became a town
which then became a city and in 1902 the
Cadillac car company was founded right
there in Detroit Michigan but what about
the crest itself it has had several
different designs throughout the years
but it has always had the patterns that
were found on Antoine delimit Cadillacs
coat of arms
one thing that was on the Explorer sigil
that used to be on the cars but isn't
anymore is a small group of ducks
Maserati when people think of Italy they
think of the country's long history and
it's definitive sense of style but it's
not just on the catwalks of Milan that
you find the Italian sense of fashion no
you can also find it in some of its
motor companies one of the ones with the
most iconic logos is Maserati the
company's story begins in the first
half of the 20th century the for
Maserati brothers Alfieri
Ettore ernesto and bingo were all
obsessed with engines their power and
their potential they made cars and
engines in the beautiful and historic
city of Bologna in the center of the
European country but when the
engineering quartet looked to come up
with a logo a new one man who could help
them out they had another brother who
wasn't so into motoring Mario Maseratis
loved was art and he was renowned
throughout the city as a fine artist
so they asked Mario to come up with
something you see the Maserati Trident
is inspired by a statue of Neptune Roman
god of the Seas that stands in the
piazza maggiore in the center of the
city so people would have seen the
three-pronged fork and associated it
immediately with Bologna now though
people might well associate it with
high-class high power cars buick buick
is one of the oldest and best known
companies that exists under the umbrella
of General Motors
well not quite as high-end as Cadillac
the Buick is a brand that uses executive
style and class but the story of its
logo is a somewhat unusual one the firm
is named dr. David Dunbar Buick who was
born in Scotland in 1854 and emigrated
to Detroit with his family aged just 2
he founded the car brand that took his
name in 1903 however his firm was bought
out by GM in 1906 and he died penniless
at the age of 74 but that isn't all
Buick never really had a logo until 1937
when a General Motors researcher
discovered the clan Buick coat of arms
in a book on heraldry this design was
placed on the grille of the radiator
that year but it wasn't until the 1950s
that the brand developed the logo that
is still synonymous with it today
someone took a stylize shield
triplicated it and colored one red one
gray and one blue to represent the three
makes of Buick Villa Sabre the Invicta
and the Electra although the tri shield
was briefly retired in favour of a hawk
nicknamed happy in the 1970s it returned
in the 1980s where it still remains
Rolls Royce if you asked a hundred
people to name the most high-class car
there is we bet you that the number one
answer would be Rolls Royce these
classic British motors
we set the standard for luxury
automobiles since they were first
produced in 1905 one of the things that
makes the roller distinctive is the
ornament on top of the hood of the car
it's called the Spirit of Ecstasy it's
story is a fascinating one in the early
20th century there was a craze for
people sticking mascots on top of their
automobiles however some people at
rolls-royce thought some of the mascots
were not appropriate for a car as classy
as theirs however one of the mascots
company bigwigs liked was the whisperer
a statue made by artist Charles Sykes
for Lord Montague they liked it so much
they asked mr. Sykes to create something
that could fit on a Rolls Royce namely
speed with silence absence of vibration
the mysterious harnessing of great
energy and a beautiful living organism
of superb grace so the Spirit of Ecstasy
a statuette of a woman her head to the
wind wearing a long flowing gown was
born and it's become associated with the
company and its cars which combined
power beauty and class ever since Alfa
Romeo car logos can run from the mundane
such as the company's name and nothing
more to the stylish and beautiful but
when it comes to a logo that's a bit
weird there's not like anything that can
match that of the Alfa Romeo it's
something that is split into two halves
and husband ever since the company was
founded back in 1910 the first part a
red cross that's the symbol of Milan the
Italian City where the firm was first
founded but it's the second half it's
the most puzzling it looks like a giant
snake which might well be wearing a
crown as if things weren't going to get
strange enough but the possibly
crown-wearing snake looks very much like
he is eating someone a bit of an odd
thing to put on a car but there's a
reason for this you see Milan was
historically associated with the
powerful Visconti family in the Middle
Ages a Tony Visconti was a knight
fighting in the Crusades he battled
against a foe who had the serpent or
possibly dragon nobody's entirely sure
on his shield and according to the
company the man isn't being eaten
instead he's actually being reborn so if
you see an Alfa Romeo don't freak out
Tesla in the world of cars it usually
pays to be innovative when a new model
or brand takes a risk quite often that
idea ends up being imitate
throughout the industry but one of the
most brilliant ideas to have been picked
up in recent years is that of the
electric car we all know that cars
create pollution which is bad for the
environment and people's health however
people still want to drive cars because
quite often they're the only way to get
somewhere
so when tesla burst onto the scene with
their electric plug-in and drive
vehicles in 2003 it caused quite a stir
here was a car which didn't use
dangerous and expensive fossil fuels but
instead just made use of a rechargeable
battery while electric powered vehicles
had been developed before they had never
been as practical and powerful as
Tesla's and we just loved the company's
logo it's very simple but we think very
clever at first glance it's just a
letter T but when you look closer it has
an extra layer it stands on a shield
which symbolises strength durability and
safety considering the reputation
electric cars had before Tesla that's a
good thing and if you wondered where the
name came from it's named after the
Serbian inventor Nikola Tesla who did
much to help develop our understanding
of electricity
Vauxhall Vauxhall is one of the biggest
car manufacturers in the UK it's
vehicles have a well deserved reputation
for stability and affordability car
models like the Astra the Cavalier and
the Corsa have wormed their way into the
British psyche but it's not just that
that makes us like Vauxhall we think
they have a really cool logo too just
look at it it's an eagle holding a flag
pretty cool right well actually it isn't
an eagle it's a Griffon if you don't
know what a gryphon is it's a heraldic
beast that's the top half of an eagle
crossed at the bottom half of a lion one
of these was on the coat of arms of a
Norman Knight called Fulks lebrandt in
the early 13th century King John of
England granted him land south of the
River Thames near London as time went on
its name got corrupted into Vauxhall
back in the 1850s Vauxhall ironworks
adopted the Griffon as its logo and it
kept it when it started to make cars in
1903 did you know that the Russian for
railway station is Vauxhall it said the
Tsar of Russia was paying a state visit
to London when he stopped at Vauxhall
station he wanted to know what the place
was called but misunderstood the answer
so when he returned to Russia the name
box all stuck Ford if there is one name
which stands above all others in a
story of the motorcar it's that of Henry
Ford it was him and his company that
helped turn the automobile from a
curious plaything for the elite into a
vital part of everyday life the
innovation by the production line
manufacturing that the firm used back in
the early 20th century helped make cars
affordable not only that but Ford was
one of the first companies to expand
internationally to the first Ford
Factory in the United Kingdom opened in
1911 and even today Ford is one of the
best selling car manufacturers in
Britain
it seems like everyone either drives or
knows someone who drives a Ford and part
of the company's success is down to
keeping things simple the Model T Ford
was able to be mass-produced at least
partly because it was only available in
black even now the company doesn't
really do fancy cars it does reliable
easy to drive and affordable vehicles
this commitment to simplicity and
accessibility is reflected in the
company's logo but contrary to what some
people might think it's not Henry Ford's
handwriting it's a design by
calligrapher childe Harold Willis but
since it's been with the company in one
form or another since 1907 we think it's
passed the test of time when have you
done something simple really well let us
know in the comments that's all for the
stories behind the world's most famous
car logos if you enjoyed it why not
check out 15 hidden images in logos you
never noticed thanks for watching and
don't forget to subscribe
[Music]